hey guys I'm Lana and I'm Noah and we
are going to be on this week's episode
of truth or dab the IUD we can delete
probably not I'm ready I'm so excited
you know what
fun fact really quit me before we get
into it I don't know if you remember
this but there was one day on set where
like I carry her out of habanero sauce
with me there's one day on set where we
were kind of bored and sleepy and so do
you remember you were in my trailer and
we we tried like tested who could have
the most hot sauce it was a huge mistake
because then we got to work we got we
want to send really good that is so fun
so I think we're gonna get they were
like cut what's wrong yes I do
everything already what's happening
let's go let's go
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another exciting episode of truth or
dab the hot ones special where we give
our guests two simple options tell the
truth or suffer the wrath of blast ab
and today I'm excited to welcome Noah
Santonio and Lana Condor together a the
star and to all the boys PS I still love
you the highly anticipated follow-up to
their 2018 hit rom-com which is set to
hit Netflix on February 12th thanks for
having me well I'm such a huge fan of
the show like I was just saying like
this was the fastest email I've ever
responded to because I saw something
absolutely I wanna be warned I've also
always like whenever I'm watching
anything tastes like what does it taste
like so I'm so happy to like finally try
it out and see what happens
yeah I'm just terrified so it's cool
Noah we'll start with you I love it go
ahead dude since you've been dubbed the
Internet's boyfriend mmm and by all
accounts a true fan and student of the
rom-com genre I know you study the likes
of Matthew McConaughey and Mark Ruffalo
mm-hmm but in real life I'm curious what
would you say was the most thoughtful
over the top romantic gesture you've
ever done for someone you're interested
in I just want to travel in these ways
yeah dive in right end off the bat which
one is this fine no mistake there's no I
snipped it right through the way right
up yep okay mm-hmm no just digging that
wing
oh my god really oh boy
you go oh my god your nose is sweating
hey so are you know which is why we have
one towel
don't eat the whole thing that's up to
you okay it's up to you guys I'm
prepared I'm crap I swear this is what
happens oh my gosh
Lana yes we'll put the attention on you
because I know that in addition to being
an actress you're also very accomplished
dancer I know that you studied with the
Joffrey Ballet yes but you know ballet
it can be such a demanding art form and
the instructors and sometimes have these
notorious reputations for being ruthless
and unforgiving is there a horror story
from your years and dance that you can
share with the Internet a horror story
from a years and danced I could share
the Internet
that's her go on well yeah I went to I I
did like a conservatory once and they
told all the girls like what we could
eat for the day and what we could eat
for the day was like an apple and like
three pieces of lettuce and I just
thought was like so traumatizing cuz
that's like a young man you're kind of
like you're so you take what's told to
you and you're kind of like oh my god
I've been you digest it so it freaked me
out a lot and I was like that's not
healthy you have to eat more than just
an apple and three lettuce think so yeah
there you have it act one in the books
know how you do it yeah Oh out of
nowhere it's you that's not that bad my
nose is dripping big eyes are a
straight-up watery it's happening it's
not so bad it's hot but it's not so bad
don't know okay I don't think I think
yours I think I've got a little singe
the eyebrows I'm sorry but by the way if
I can just comment on that that's the
same yes I've heard that about ballet
many alright I want you to get real
about your co-star Noah can you rank the
following Noah sent an AO films from
best to work I like this question what
you guys do best to work
almost to work they're all bad but you
know work on it see how Burgess is a
loser the perfect date
SPF 18 I'm not yeah I'm not doing that
I can't okay I'm going in she can't do
that because she hasn't seen any of them
I'm curiosity have you seen turkle's no
no I despise you well whoa oh good
borrow my towel if you want probably buy
you a the whole thing most of it there's
some you know there are some just as
good just as good as Noah
you got it Noah yeah buddy and 2019 you
guys won an MTV Movie Award for Best
Kiss so my guess is Lana is not in the
conversation but who knows that's why
you play the game truth or dare
no of all your on-screen love interests
who was the worst on-screen kisser hawai
oh it's building baby do better the
whole day yeah yeah did you take a drink
you know
man I should've I should have I should
have answered the other one and I should
have ate one on this one that's kind of
how we lined it yeah it's smart my god
so here's the thing when I was 11 years
old
I did a movie called gold retrievers I
did it just before turbos and I was 11
years old and I had it yet kissed a girl
and so I was on screen up in a tree
and they were like yeah I just kissed
really quick and I was like uh I've
never kissed a girl man and I how are
you kidding oh my god you can take a sip
I'll take a sip if you want to take
yourself okay
wait no no wait your dog
so we kissed on screen it was my first
kiss in the world that I and after I saw
it I Spit just cuz I was like all thrown
off by and that's kind of amazing your
first kiss in life was almost not scream
life of an actor I was robbed
yeah lot of you've extended for us I
think I touched them with don't don't
don't touch you know how do you bring
five towels on set and then end up
touching your eyes you know you know
what I'm saying you know some reason I'm
not the sharpest tool shed my guy is it
not building on you okay it'll go away I
promise did you know that's a bull
tongue Lana we're gonna keep the
attention on you over here yeah because
your co-star he's known for these
philosophical musings on Twitter a high
light beam how long does it take to fall
in love it depends how fast you jump
come on now so yes so with that in mind
I want to play a little game called
who said it Noah or play-doh I'll give
you the quote no man if you tell me a
mantra you got this if Noah said it or
if Plato says there is a difference it's
all three right and you're in the clear
but one wrong did my chest okay let's go
we're gonna chase it we're gonna chase
that water you chest how this goes
first up yep you got this come on it's a
blessing and a curse to look behind the
curtain Noah or play
[Music]
that's a Noah
that is a Noah yeah it isn't Noah Lana's
still alive here Lana come on yeah this
next Anna's I sometimes saying how you
feel is powerful enough to change how
you feel I just get a quick eye contact
that is a Noah that is Noah that is Noah
we are together to love one more to go
love is a serious mental disease
that's a Noah that comes from Plato dang
Archer Lana it's fine it's fine
I know that's fine that's fine just one
bite oh no look don't you see it it's
like way where it's probably just don't
just you know a little tiny nipple I'm
shaking Jesus Christ
Noah as we previously mentioned you've
been dubbed the Internet's boyfriend
which while flattery yeah seems like a
potentially difficult relationship to
keep up do you have one complaint about
how fans are blogs handle the
relationship with you online because if
there is a lover's quarrel I think
truther dab is the place to air that out
yeah so okay so what's interesting with
that whole like relationship I love that
you're next to me going through
something right now it's a bizarre
setting about it like nothing's
happening what's interesting is you do
things and then people all of a sudden
are like what the [ __ ] are you doing I
encourage all right I'm not allowed to
you'll be put out if I'm not you'll put
like a little rooster or something you
know you make funny decisions as a joke
to yourself and your friends and like
like bleaching a beard and then people
are like oh [ __ ] you like what are you
doing to my face and you're like no no
it's my face you know so it's just but I
don't have qualms with that I think it's
an interesting dynamic how people feel
like they you know they they have this
ownership way it's like this one you're
all should I just eat this one do we
have any more questions do we got one
more question
there's one more question as we'll eat
this right I feel like you know keys
then then it's this but then it's this
one we got to be on the same page I got
you what a co-star oh let's make some
noise reduction fire clapping all six
people
holy [ __ ] all right I'm with you now I
feel it almost it's not if everyone on
the same wavelength
except for me sub you always fine I'm
not pissed at you me I can just say
really quick though I really have
complaints enjoy being the Internet's
boyfriend it's an honor I'm not saying
you can't judge me I feel like you're
entitled to an opinion about my face you
know [ __ ] it it's your face too
you know I'm saying we're in this
together this is a this is a mutualistic
relationship so I love you if you have a
problem with me go ahead say it
we'll talk about it
[Music]
do you late hey you little dragon
alright I want that in slow motion whoa
alright this last question it's a team
effort it's for both of you guys
anticipation for this near Valentine's
Day release of to all the boys I've
loved PS I still love you is high and
there is already a tidal wave of fan
theories online rumors about this love
triangle so at the risk of maybe getting
a wrist slap from Netflix possibly sued
who knows Luca who does large gene end
up with in this film Peter or John
Ambrose McLaren
I just coming up baby you're a dick
this is coming movie it's okay hold on
hold on no no you look at me before I
was owners free gonna no you're not
freaking out a little bit okay I am I
won't be sued did I have a reason to
freak out before yes yeah you're the
only sane one right huh
me nope okay but this is what I'm saying
is you're saying you're irrational right
person you're saying you're rational
yeah you know we're gonna get through
this we have other people of Davis
really oh you're gonna do this and I'm
gonna do this we're through this you
know and this is temporary
yes February 3 to kill one chills
I did okay
what a run done the truth or dab
gauntlet to co-stars sticking by each
other's side supporting each other when
they need it most
make sure to check out to all the boys
I've loved PS I still love you
February 12 applix that is awesome dude
that was such a elbow okay that was how
you feel oh this is Sean Evans checking
in to tell you about the hot ones hot
sauce box and guess what just that fast
it can be yours and if you're on the
fence about it February is a good month
why because we have a super exclusive
super special never before tasted
never-before-seen hot ones super hot and
I know what you're thinking
I'll Lowe's calientes Rojo I know about
that ahh oh you guys did another version
of the last app aren't wrong again in
this February box is a new hot ones
super hot that you have not seen before
as well as two other sauces curated by
heat missed only one way to get your
hands on the great mystery box of
February and that's to visit heat nice
calm heat nice calm heat nice calm to
order pick up your box before just like
that
they're gone bang-bang